bonjour à tous bienvenue à espace
autochtones en direct merci de nous
retrouver comme tous les vendredi à
12h15 en direct alors je vous présente
l'équipe est notre invité spécial
aujourd'hui l'invité karen pinède
centaine bonjour car elle est originaire
de vachette malioténam trets est il du
côté droit charles du côté de malioténam
d'ailleurs maliotenam malioténam
d'accord alors qu'à rennes est avec nous
aujourd'hui elle va chanter elle se
prépare un spectacle qu'elle va donner
ce soir à la place des arts de montréal
ouah ça c'est génial donc on aura droit
déjà à deux de ses chansons et on va
parler de ce spectacle évidemment que
vous ne faites pas tout seul il ya
plusieurs personnes sur scène oui oui on
est quatre auteurs compositeurs
interprètes autochtone et quatre auteurs
compositeurs non autochtone a pas plus
avec les mentors qui sont en juin si je
compte mettre cap ferret flaran voilà
marc déry guillaume arsenault et réjean
bouchard voilà alors on va aussi parler
aujourd'hui avec mathis harvey qui
remplace celis quinn qui est parti on ne
se soumettrait loin mathis bonjour un
jour alors matisse avec vous on va
parler de réglementation sur la vente
d'alcool dans les territoires exact donc
la réglementation sur les la vente
d'alcool la consommation d'alcool peut
reprendre le cas précis de coûts plutôt
que dans leur ouest du 9 août qui avait
mené à référendum dès cette semaine et
embrassait on va faire une survole ce
qu'il en est dans le nord-ouest du
canada puis il s'est aussi aux normes
avec d'accord et puis charles de batz
comme bonjour chers jeunes
oui alors charles avec vous on savait à
toronto oui ça va te retrouves cette
semaine découvrir une exposition sur sur
l'identité sur la présence de
francophones anglophones autochtone de
l'allant
ce grand territoire avec et avec 3
autochtone qui ne sont aucunement
originaire de toronto pour exister
alors avant on se retourne vers karen
karen vous avez une histoire
intéressante parce que oui je les dis
vous êtes chanteuse mais vous êtes aussi
cinéaste
oui je suis je fais partie 2-2 le
connais depuis connu parce que c'est
comme ça que vous avez commencé
d'ailleurs dans le monde artistique
oui c'est aussi dans la grâce avec
wapikoni mobile mais aussi avec aussi
dans ma jeunesse là avec avec les cours
de théâtre les cours de théâtre musical
et cours de g mais qu'est ce qui est
arrivé dans votre vie en premier chanter
ou faire du cinéma
chanter c'est sur wii vous chantiez tout
ça sur dans la communauté amalio comme
ça dans la rue non oui je sais tu es
plus plus chez moi avec avec avec ma
famille mes parents il y avait toujours
de la musique
la radio était toujours allumée chez moi
donc je t'ai pour être on était une
famille mélomane oui et puis
éventuellement le wapikoni est arrivé en
tournée un maillot tena mais là vous
avez décidé d'y prendre part oui oui en
premier la première fois que je suis au
lycée plus faire là c'est un peu par
faire le montage faire de l'aide dans
les plateaux de tournage - et donc c'est
ce qui m'a vraiment qui m'a plus
intéressé plus intérêts de quelques
réalisations
oui ça vous a permis de découvrir aussi
cet univers cinématographique est en
fait on sait parler la première fois je
vous avais parlé il ya quoi déjà presque
deux ans maintenant pour bataille
bataille c'est votre premier court
métrage est ce que c'est le premier vous
avez fait en tant que réalisatrice avec
le wapikoni oui oui j'ai en tout il y en
a deux qui a été que j'ai réalisé avec
le wapikoni noué il ya un matin que j'ai
écouté je sais pas combien de fois
j'essaie de j'essaie de le comprendre là
alors on va raconter c'est quoi un matin
en fait un matin c'est une jeune femme
qui est assise devant son bol de
céréales et dans son bol de céréales il
ya ces céréales qui sont des lettres de
l'alphabet et on voit des mots qui se
forment
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous voulez
dire à travers ce est ce que quelqu'un
de vous la vue non je pense que je les
ai vus je sais quelque chose
qu'est ce qu'on peut voir dans les
images c'est tout en blanc et tous oui
c'est très monochrome blanc oui c'est
exact dans le bol de céréales c'est
écrit plein de vie qui ont eu des
attentats dans les dernières années
comme par exemple orlando a initié ces
cas où c'est la syrie aussi paris aussi
avec ce qui s'est passé donc ça tourne
autour du thème des attentes qui se
passe n'est permis
c'est ça il est très fort depuis mr je
vous raconte pas le punch il faut aller
voir il ya un personnage et un bol de
céréales la céréale flamand avec les
lettres de l'alphabet c'est pour mon bet
transmettre de tom comme un côté comme
on peut le voir dans la simplicité de la
le serial de le faire mais en même temps
c'est intéressant parce que nous on est
chez nous dans un pays protégés ont
souvent protégés en tout cas et là on
mange nos céréales on ne s'imaginant pas
tout ce qui peut se passer ailleurs
comme tragédie de ce genre là oui
je sais de transe matters alors alors ce
film là c'est un matin il a été réalisé
en 2016 donc il ya eu une bataille
et puis il ya eu un vidéoclip pour une
de vos chansons
oui ça séné comment est ce que la
chanson est née avant le vidéoclip le
vidéoclip a été inspiré de la chanson
dernier train
la chanson est inspiré à voir le vidéo
clip
ça faisait tellement traîné dans mes
cahiers donc j'ai décidé de l'écrire de
le composer le jeu les jeux les jouets
avec chansons rassembleuse mais aussi
j'ai montré ma composition wapikoni qui
sont proposées ce que je vous propose
c'est parce qu'on verra pas le vidéoclip
mon pourrez écouter la chanson
les huit derniers trains oui ok vous
imaginez ça on est à mme alliot on est
sur une route et il ya karen qui
chantent mon écoute je crois que je vais
bien si je sache que jours malgré tout
c'est juste pour aller fumer
[Musique]
de tourner la page mais à chaque essai
j'ai rien que ça va plus c'est loupé
je ne pense pas d'ailleurs
[Musique]
l'étalonnage jusqu'en
toujours et calmes et watch et je crois
que je vais attendre aucun changement
[Musique]
ailleurs je vous attends quoi vous y
tient
[Musique]
ce jour
mais je devrais y aller maintenant qui
le dernier chan est assez neutre étant
je veux plus que 4 et de garder la télé
je crois que je vais passer ou que tu
t'y jma ailleurs je vais mourir
c'est un point précis
[Musique]
e
ah ah
[Musique]
e
le pop a sonné
mais si par sat embrasser
toner a su assez à shenzhen de jeu
mauvais
c'est triste en même temps un départ
comme ça oui oui c'est surtout le sujet
comme de mon monde a envie de partir
pour élargir mes horizons et du coup
pour mes études y aussi pour mon mac à
des artistes artistique au cinéma et en
chanson oui mais qu'est ce donc
c'est exact ça voulait dire aussi
quitter ma famille quitter mes amis donc
c'est pour ça la création de dernier
traîne
cette pièce est ce que vous allez la
chanter ce soir dans le spectacle
présenté à la place des arts non mais il
a été joué au début début de chanson
rassembleuse on avait chacun
chaque artiste a présenté leurs propres
chansons dans leur de leur propre
répertoire mais moi j'avais celui là
alors donc on a eu de la chance
aujourd'hui une exclusivité oui
absolument
alors qu'à rennes ne vous ne bougez pas
on se sont tout de suite vers mathis
parce que mathis on part avec vous dans
le grand nord
on va aller visiter les grands
territoires canadiens que ce soit quand
le duc en una voûte le nunavik
on va aller à la découverte en fait des
communautés que l'on appelle sèche
d'abord explications avant qu est ce qu
une communauté sèche communauté c'est en
fait cette semaine communauté ou la
vente et la consommation d'alcool sont
en fait interdite par soit le conseil
municipal où le conseil de ben oui donc
en anglais les drailles qui me disent
finalement il y en a plusieurs à travers
le canada
et puis on a même si on navigue en fait
le code 11 des 14 communautés inuit
neuvic qui n'auraient pas tout mais les
3000 à l'exception c'est donc ce sont
couleur à pique couvert les toqués coup
jack d'accord alors si on repart
maintenant pour l'ensemble du territoire
canadien
en fait ça change et des communautés qui
ne sont pas sèche qui veulent le devenir
ou inversement et il ya toute sorte
d'exemple en fait on va parler d'un
village inuit qui se trouve vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure en ouverture à
kugluktuk exact ça c'est le nord-ouest
du nunavut et eux sont passés au
référendum on leur demandait s'ils
voulaient vivre dans une communauté
c'est chou communautés non sèche oui en
fait ce qui s'est passé c'est claudie
donc la communauté la communauté de
corrupteur quand le référendum
on a une carte lation aussi on peut
regarder la carte puisque ça se trouve à
environ
on est dans la à proximité de la mer de
beaufort donc imaginez vous nord-ouest
du nunavut
donc ça fait les points rouges dans le
nunavut et représenter paysage par les
chemises rouges mais comme le coup n'est
pas représentée par un des points
suivants vont revoir la carte tout à
l'heure mais en fait ici vous avez
toutes les communautés sèche donc
répertorié que j'ai répertorié donc au
yukon en jambes en verre dans les
territoires du nord-ouest ont rouge où
la voûte et on avait parlé tous les
petits points rouges d'accord ouais
alors revenons à l'exemple de plus
glauque tongs en espèces non clérical en
date de lundi en fait c'est que la
communauté a décidé de à 70% les
résidents ont décidé de passer à un
système non restrictif ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est comparable y avait un
comité est composé de membres élus par
la communauté qui valider ou non les
demandes d'achats d'alcool
donc c'était le comité d'éducation à la
consommation d'alcool et c'était
beaucoup du cas par cas parce qu' il
fallait étudier le profil du demandeur
en question soit en fonction du
comportement du demandeur d ont baissé
dans judiciaire oui et puis dans le fond
cette communauté a opté pour la levée de
ces restrictions la puis on voit que
c'est c'est c'est chaque communauté peut
décider ou non en fait
ce à quoi elles voient dans quelle
direction elle va laisser lever si elle
décide de tenir un référendum pour lever
ces restrictions se décide de devenir
une communauté sèche et en fait on se
rend compte aussi que les les
communautés donc en fait peuvent établir
les
les réflexions les règles qu'elles
veulent donc si je vous donne quelques
exemples la diversité de gestion en fait
de ses réflexes selon les communes cc
n'ya pas de balises précises accord il
ya plusieurs stratégies aux procédures
qui peuvent être mises en place
on peut laisser une communauté peut les
citer par exemple de limiter la quantité
d'établir des quotas donc de limiter la
quantité maximale qui avait une personne
veuve dollars pour l'achat donc par
exemple à la coopérative donc la co-op
de puvirnituq les résidents peuvent
acheter au maximum par jour
une bouteille devrait vous donner un
ordre d'idée c'est une tête de vin coûte
environ 50 $ donc à approuver une tour
le clavier temps élevé bien sûr et puis
pour la bière c'est 12 câble est donc
une caisse de 12 km au maximum par jour
au québec c'est encore là c'est propre à
chaque communauté a couvert les taux qui
a un restaurant et la coopérative qui
s'est passé de se procurer de l'alcool a
coulé à pic
il ya deux bars restaurants mais la
coopérative ne vend pas d'alcool
chaque communauté décide ne peut à sa
guise s'il en est sinon à part les
hélicos taille et aussi la possibilité
de fermer deux des amies ont des
restrictions dans les dents les heures
d'ouverture enfin des magasins des bords
ok un coup dur rapide par exemple le bar
ferme à 23h30 la semaine ça c'est une
stratégie qui peut être employé sinon
les comités élu par les membres de la
communauté comme les codes de coupe peut
par exemple
et puis encore sinon encore autre chose
qui peut être établie par la communauté
c'est d'établir une liste noire
ça c'est qu'en partenariat entre le
conseil municipalle conseil de bande et
la police régionale
et en fait quand quelqu'un commet un
délit sous l'emprise de l'alcool pendant
une certaine période de temps qui nous
terminons en fonction de la gravité du
délit
oui et loup elle ne peut pas se procurer
de l'alcool donc il peut même pas se
rendre si un restaurant dans la
communauté ne peut même pas se rendre au
restaurant et acheter de l'alcool c'est
une bonne question mais je peux vous
garantir que la cour pour lui refuse la
l'autorisation d'acheter de l'alcool
c'est dans le conseil d'accord d'accord
ok alors maintenant on pourrait se
promener en fait à travers à travers les
différents territoires parce que c'est
ça il ya certaines communautés qui sont
sèches d'autres qui ne le sont pas et
chacun a décidé selon ses critères donc
c'est ça si on peut re peut-être avoir
la carte et donc nous avons six
communautés qui ont groupes qui sont
sèches ou au tertre du nord-ouest hier
de 7 alors que l'accord du nord-ouest
les boutons vesle petites puces vertes
verte heureux et puis le petit col
exception hugon c'est le code à la
communauté de crau ou en fait la
communauté en fait là c'est à dire 10 de
consommer d'acheter de l'alcool dans son
périmètre de 100 kilomètres du centre
communautaire
donc on voit que c'est le seul fait
l'option est du coup en jaune ont joué
voilà moi j'ai une question à propos de
l'alcool et les réserves sèche
est ce qu'à ce moment là les la
contrebande d'alcool vont monter en
flèche
et puis c'est sûr que c'est toujours un
peu quand on parlait aussi par rapport
au cannabis et c'est toujours le danger
évidemment bon il ya là
la vente illicite la production illicite
par ce curieux qui produisent leur
promet d'en concocter avec me lasse je
pense me lasse fruits oui fruits
éleveurs je pensé en fonction de la
teneur en ingrédients
c'est exact donc c'est pour ça justement
qu'il ya des communautés qu'ils disent
mais on veut lever ces restrictions là
parce que ça me fait qu'encourager la
vente initiée une autre bombe examen on
va fixer des balises
comme je voulais tout simplement mais on
n'en fixera peuple c'est le cas des
communautés où il n'ya pas de régime
restrictif donc oui il se fie aux lois
provinciales tout simplement j'ai une
question pour vous deux
mashteuiatsh j'essaie encore de pratique
et de machines et malioténam ça ne peut
pas être des communautés ça je vous êtes
trop proche des grands centres non bain
par contre ma ce voyage c'est pas une
communauté sèche il ya de l'alcool qui
se vend dans la communauté
mais par contre y'a pas de ne pas de bar
on peut pas rester là où ce qui se
vendent de l'alcool c'est parce que
c'est dans la communauté je pense que
c'est déréglementé chaque communauté va
être vraiment différent que marouane
d'akébé varrault des restaurants
bousquet va pouvoir acheter de l'alcool
c'est oui oui ok c'est pas c'est pas la
même réglementation donc c'est même pour
la chasse et la communauté berrahma
story je crois qu'on n'a même pas loin
de chasse et une nuits mais tandis que
la loi au canada nous l'autorisé
oui mais c'est pour une question de
sécurité donc c'est vraiment c'est
propre à chaque communauté qui décèdent
cédé 10 min gouvernement on pourrait
dire bien sûr oui car elle même chose
donc à maria tena oui c'est la même
chose que lui
on essaie aussi des comme m
intégrer que dans dans des événements
comme par exemple festival et non un
gros mot que c'est votre sec
non ils ne vendent pas d'alcool depuis
le début donc ce soit ya des choses
comme ce qui fait qu' on essaie de je
pense que je suis pas commandé de
[Musique]
protéger peut-être c'est toujours dans
l'optique de résoudre les deux multi la
consommation estime quand on regarde les
statistiques on dit je pense en 2012
pour les ennemis de 15 ans cela je
prends le cas inuit mais si on regarde
les 8 mondial qui regroupe les quatre
régions les quatre territoires où on
retrouve les mêmes et au canada oui au
nord oui au nunavik par exemple en 2012
il y avait 34 % des détenus qui
consommaient de manière abusive de
l'alcool pour celui qui l'a le
territoire qui situe en bête de laisser
le nunatsiavut au nord de terre-neuve et
labrador où la taille est un peu plus de
45%
un master miage d'exemples de ce qu'est
ce je crois que j'ai eu un moment donné
il y avait une partie des ventes
d'alcool qu'elle est à la famille pour
des organismes de famille dans la
communauté donc une caisse de 24 ans 22
dollars dans la communauté agricole va
se vendre
19 dollars 1,12 dollar qui je crois
qu'avec un système comme ça à l'époque
lou jeu c'est encore comme seul mais je
pense que des sites en com soit pour
contribuer bien qu'ils aient des
problèmes d'alcool c'est la famille qui
souffre dans lequel je pense que ce
souhait de contribuer tout est là
matisse le cannabis est légal depuis
déjà une dizaine de jours on n'a pas
commencé à réglementer ouais c'est sûr
que c'est une scène le ballon passait à
côté la gamme de parler de
réglementation en matière de le monde
d'alcool sont sans parler de la question
est ce que on pourra est ce qu'on peut
parler d'eux on pourra parler de
communauté à la fois sèche et sans fumée
c'est pas possible on l'a vu déjà au
québec dans le sud du québec il ya des
communautés autochtones qui ont décidé
d'établir des balises pour mieux
réglementer la vente la congrégation la
culture du cannabis chez les 1 6 km de
manawan c'est ils ont décidé que ce
serait interdit de l'ong de consommer de
l'alcool dans les lieux de dialyse
pardon les lieux publics comme c'est le
cas pour l'alcool d'accord donc une
communauté qui en compte cinq se sont
positionnés au nunavik par contre à
l'administration régionale kativik on
n'a pas pu me dire si il n'y a pas pour
l'instant de discussions allant dans le
sens d'établir des restrictions par
rapport à la la consommation la vente de
cannabis oui mais on m'a dit que c'était
pas c'était pas le possible par contre
que ça devienne un argument pour les
candidats qui vont se présenter aux
élections municipales en mai communauté
le 7 novembre les maudits c'est pas ça
pas été abordé mais c'est pas impossible
que ça soit un argument ensuite au
nunavut non plus il n'y a pas de
restriction ou d'interdiction prévu on
est comme une communauté conduit sur la
carte tout à l'heure dans les
territoires du nord-ouest en fait c'est
les communautés qui
les boutiques spécialisées devait ouvrir
des boutiques spécialisées devant des
canaris devaient ouvrir il fallait que
il fallait que les communautés tienne un
référendum avant de cet acteur pour se
positionner sur la question celle n'y a
pas de boutiques spécialisées encore
peuvent à n'importe quel moment choisi
mais c'est dans les territoires du
nord-ouest avant de régler ça je pense
qu'il devrait régler le coût de la
nourriture des choses comme ça en fait
partout on veut planter on veut planter
des magasins pour vendu potes mais le
résultat est juste après ça coûte
extrêmement cher la ville
l'exemple de l'alcool ces deux trois
fois puis je peux parler du conte mais
les municipalités aussi mon pouvoir
évidemment se positionner établir leurs
propres règles pour créer des règlements
pour l'emplacement aussi des magasins
mais pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
colle de communauté qui couperait des
démineurs que j'ai contacté pas eu de
communauté qui s'est positionné en corse
m
on connaît pas non plus la position de
vos communautés mais éventuellement mais
j'ai parlé tout au bout de territoire
bien sûr dans ce cas la regarder oui
voila merci beaucoup matisse mais c'est
vrai que ça on va en parler dans un
autre facebook l'arrivée on va
s'intéresser à lhassa cette réalité là
et c'est déjà pas ma communauté de
cannabis le cannabis illégal de janvier
déjà un fléau donc ils ont fait pas de
soucis de 10 des 2 2 peuvent se faire
exclure de la communauté
[Musique]
alors le temps passe vite pour ceux qui
se joignent à nous c'est un facebook
live vous voyez on est en direct avec
karen pinette fontaine car elle je
disais vous allez être je le disais plus
tôt pour ceux qui étaient là vous allez
être sur scène ce soir à la place des
arts avec des artistes autochtones et
non autochtones ça fait parti d'un elle
alla d'un grand travail de création qui
a commencé il ya un an et demi c'était
au printemps 2017 vous vous êtes réunis
pour la première fois oui mais
ouais à petite-vallée en gaspésie
première déconvenue est-ce que c'était
parce que vous vous êtes rencontrés
entre artistes autochtones et non
autochtones est ce que c'était la
première fois que vous aviez dans votre
cas précis à travailler avec des non
autochtones
mais je vois le travail en équipe sa
première fois que j'ai sauté planète
hockey oui c'était la première fois que
ce genre de deux résidences le désastre
des changes entre autochtones et non
autochtones dans le dans le catégorie de
la musique que je fais ça avec le
théâtre au second en a mais c'est ça
avec la musique ça a été quand même
différent sur un an et demi comment vous
avez évolué là dedans parce qu'il ya eu
donc la première résidence de création
vous avez fait vous avez enregistré des
chansons sur disque m
là sur disque sur cd je sais pas trop ce
que vous étiez dans le studio de fleurs
en volant à malioténam donc le travail
que vous avez fait ensemble dans cette
création là vous avez pu l'enregistrer
aussi ensuite vous êtes retrouvés sur
scène déjà aussi les sommes avec
chansons rassembleuse on a eu beaucoup
de 2,2 d'attentes de date
donc on a eu ce spectacle sur scène vous
avez le day2 nikamu entre autres l'année
dernière vous étiez à stival la chance
d'en petites manies c'est vrai à québec
cette année en fait à lévis cette année
dont vous avez déjà été sur scène
plusieurs fois vous même qu'est ce que
vous retirer de tout ça de cette
expérience c'est sûr c'est qu'est-ce que
j'en retire ce serait 10 ans
le feu on peut que ça soit dans les os
le sport ou n'importe quoi c'est dense
dans les loisirs je crois qu'on peut
créer une conversation rassemblement
entre autochtones et non autochtones et
c'est ça qui a beaucoup aidé marchand
sont rassembleuses a créé deux les
conversations en la majorité des
colonisations sur les réalités chez chez
les inuits et les attikameks mais
c'était à cause que l'on faisait de la
musique qu'on écrivait on écrit des
paroles chaque chacun et chacune était
curieuse de l'un et l'autre les notes
autorités étaient eux étaient restés sur
notre histoire est une réalité exacte et
c'est ce que je retiendrai que il faut
c'est que tout le monde aime la même
chose donc à cause que de ce que je
pense que on peut mais des fois on lui
connaît pas un big ben on aime les mêmes
choses on a les mêmes intérêts oui
absolument
alors charles y en a trois qui se sont
réunis à toronto de trois communautés
différentes eux aussi se sont rendus
compte qu'il y avait des intérêts
communs premier intérêt peut-être le
territoire le territoire intéresse tout
le monde
exactement on s'y retrouve tous c'est un
événement qui se déroule à toronto
jusque là l'idée 112 le semble et ça
s'appelle toronto exemple alors qu'il a
organisé cet événement là qu'est ce que
c'est c'est de l'art contemporain c'est
oui en fait c'est un exposition d'art
quant à paris un autochtone
qui présentait à toronto jusqu'au 12
décembre puis c'est le labo en
collaboration avec le why why cie de
toronto le labo est en fait une centre
d'artistes francophones à toronto
donc ils ont approché guy sioui durand
pour être commissaire de l'exposition
donc le penseur de toute cette idée là
pour pour donner c'est pour donner vie à
cette exposition là est donc juste pour
faire un petit peu l'histoire de 401
richman a se trouve est un édifice avec
plusieurs centres d'artistes donc oui
c'est un bâtiment puisque plusieurs
grains plusieurs centres d'artistes ou
ce que les les les artistes peuvent
louer prendre local fade et des communs
qu'on appelle ça des airs performant
même pas l'idée de performance des
résidences voilà c'est certain les
résidences d'artistes donc voilà et puis
c'est ce qui est proposé ce dialogue se
trialog en fait parce que ce trou silguy
et à deux autres artistes dont sonia
robertson et simon et mme bénédicte qui
est sinon et abénakis et sunu du lac
saint jean donc voilà il est proposé ce
ce projet laisse une forme de sur un
thème qui s'appelle toronto toronto en
langue rwandaise qui veut dire là où les
habitants proche du lac ontario a
exactement de bord de ces pour
représenter aussi là l'achalandage la
connexion qui avait entre les rivières
dans le temps dans l'époque de traite de
la fourrure donc c'est ainsi qu'au
québec
chaque grande ville de gt1 poste de
traite ou un lieu de rassemblement pour
les autochtones et les francophones et
les anglophones
donc on est en territoire anglophones à
toronto mais il ya des francophones
aussi mais il y avait aussi des
autochtones
donc c'est pour représente un peu cette
présence autochtone l'ocet ces langues
qui qui qui s'échangeaient entre les
entre les autochtones les francophones
et les anglophones
donc c'est vraiment peau pour essayer de
faire rayonner cette présence la dent
dans toronto lé qui équipent qingli fait
que dans cette note expulsé lors guy
sioui durand vous l'avez dit c'est le
commissaire il ya les deux artistes deux
assists alors comment ça se traduit sur
/ en fait dans cette
d'exposition là qu'ont fait les deux
artistes bien j'ai une fois tout
justement de l'oeuvre de l'installation
de sournia robertson
qui nous étaient fournis par le labo
sonia a fait une installation sûre je
sais pas si on peut voir l'oeuvre de
sonia à l'écran alors c'est là qu'elle
se l'offre c'est là l'offre ronde c'est
la vraie ronde exact il ya cette offre
qu'elle a fait c'est une peau de castor
géant où ce qu'est une projection dessus
sonia le en fait c'est ma tante et le
nom de la même de la même famille voilà
on la voit juste ici donc on vient d'une
famille où ce que son père était et est
fort rare qu'on appelle donc acheté la
fourrure ah oui donc fabriquer des
manteaux des chapeaux des choses comme
ça donc c'est quelque chose à avec le
lien c'est un lien avec quel lot de très
près dans sa famille dont lé décidé
d'utiliser cette peau de castor pour
pouvoir représenter aussi la traite de
la fourrure donc ça parle de tout ça
aussi elle a pris également des images
l'intérieur du lac ontario s'est promené
avec une caméra et puis c'est dans le
fond du lac est exactement dans le fond
du lac c'est le lac ontario manille et
puis beaucoup avec les énergies on a le
fleuve saint-laurent aussi qui
représentait par les fleuves les eaux
qui sont représentés par le bleu donc
c'est ce qui permet aussi de pouvoir de
pouvoir communiquer de pouvoir échanger
les ce sont elles et très bonne cette
symbolique là parce qu'en fait le castor
lui ont dit qu'ils représentent
à l'origine ils représentent les lacs à
loreley le centre avec le lac des
castors le nom de l'oeuvre qui n'est pas
masqué nom qui veut dire les chemins
d'eau donc les premières nations se
déplaçait coupable s'est jamais eu bien
sûr qu'à nous donc voilà c'est une
installation il travaille aussi beaucoup
avec l'utilisation de l'espace donc
voilà et pour simon simon aymes
bénédicte lui travaille beaucoup dans le
dans le vidéo contemporain il n'est pas
nécessairement à caractère autochtones
du pays
il n'a pas vécu en commun il n'y a pas
de vécu en communauté lui était vécue il
ya des vécus à l'extérieur de la
communauté danse
et c'est un peu il fait un peu comme il
ya envie de découvrir qu'il est son
identité un retour sur ses retours sur
lui même donc je pense que je pense que
pour mme chirac qu'autochtones n'est pas
vécue dans sa commune il ya quelque
chose qu'il l'appelle dans le rouge bien
qui je suis je pense que c'est important
ou si tu sais si on sait qu'on est
cessible
c'est un rôle assez de lui c'est de lui
en fait c'est pas c'est pas seulement
juste ça c'est un vidéo d'à peu près une
dizaine de minutes qui qui est très
contemporain en fait qui regroupe à peu
près 400 images d'archivés la
bibliothèque et archives du canada donc
c'est déjà fait des recherches comme
hymne des autochtones pensionnat donc
fédérer il a essayé de catégoriser ces
sites ces images avec un travail aussi
le sont donc ces il permet aussi
d'intégrer des bandes sonores
contemporaine là dedans donc ça ça vient
tout se mélange et tout ce ce signifiant
donc on veut une vidéo de d'un certain
nombre de temps et puis travaille
beaucoup sur le lézard médiatique et la
vidéo ok voilà ça s'est présenté donc
jusqu'au 12 décembre qu'on a le temps
d'y aller si on passe par toronto
fallait au la blague qui est un des
grands centres artistiques francophones
de tous les labos exactement ça c'est et
puis c'est le sait où 400 km en
autonomie on connaît l'adresse
maintenant 400 euros x men c'est ça
merci beaucoup ce fait divers
karen une des pièces que vous avez
travaillé avec cet atelier cette
résidence de création c'est le blanc des
yeux
est ce qu'elle est née à partir de
l'atelier de création où c'est une
chanson qui existait déjà dans votre
tête et où vous avez déjà composé
incertaine en pendant l'atelier de
création la première première semaine
qui est devenu uniquement ma mi automne
c'était en premier
il fallait se mettre en équipe pour
créer des nouvelles chansons il y a mais
neuf et joël st pierre qui montrent
comment approcher pied du conte fascine
chez quelque chose ensemble
on a fait quelque chose ensemble il ya
mathieu qui s'est rajouté par la suite
donc à fives c'est une création que le
blanc des yeux
pourquoi le blanc des yeux c'est fort le
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses là je te
regardent dans le blanc des yeux mais
enfin que tu oui mais on sait aussi
beaucoup basé sur l'extérieur c'est ce
que qui est basé beaucoup sur
la tv la télévision dans les années
50-60 avec les indiens et les cow boys
on sait on a tourné autour de seuils on
essaie de dire au public de ne pas se
fier sur ce au regard des passants
regardent et nous écouter et nous parler
dans les nous ces sacs etc c'est autour
de ce cancer
l'affirmation du blanc exact on va
l'écouter justement le blanc des yeux
comme ça on va pouvoir bien entendre ce
texte vous avez écrit donc avec mathiot
et avec joël st pierre le blanc des yeux
que vous allez interpréter ce soir oui
elle fait partie du spectacle on écoute
[Musique]
fait hum on voit pas mais voient la
couleur de ma peau
les parts ou pas
que je me lève tôt le batteur jay de
vivre mais pas telle que je m'accroche à
mes amis mais je n'irai jamais pu voir
tout ce qu'on peut voir dans les taux de
télévision ne sont que des vision naïve
[Musique]
imagination je connais pas la danse du
soleil
j'vois pas de queue de cornet je dois
faille dans mon tipi je cherche maliens
d'aller pisser car témoin dans le bain
[Musique]
zigert d'amour dans le blanc
je me marre talent que j'ai écrit à bien
leur projet un peu pour tout le monde et
je n'ai pas pas d'ailleurs
[Musique]
pourtant le vent
car dans le bois
[Musique]
je suis sur dix 8 604 des minimums des
idiomes actes je suis 118 604 tu peux
vérifier sur mac à peu car tempo dans le
blanc des yeux comme témoin dans le nord
monsieur le
oh
coeur des mois km2 dans le plat
t je vais être le premier averti qu'un
album et la suite avec niqab ou mamoun
il y aura éventuellement un album oui
ben il ya eu déjà la première phase ii
pour faire un album l'ailé on va dire
les cinq premières chansons west valley
on a créé d'autres nouvelles chansons
saint-augustin-de-desmaures oui pendant
sa honda ou et on a maintenant dix on a
eu dix on a fait dix chansons oui ces
productions un album tout le monde à
voir ce soir sur scène faut venir à la
place des arts de montréal pour venir
vous voir ce soir donc à 20h à la
cinquième salle de la place des arts bon
spectacle karen merci beaucoup merci
pour votre visite dans notre studio
merci beaucoup charles maxime ou à la
semaine prochaine et mathis aussi à la
semaine prochaine et pour vous aussi la
semaine prochaine 12h15 pour un autre
facebook live d'ici ici ici oui là est
ce parce que direct merci à la semaine
prochaine